наріжте у господь і
марія нестеренка можна заткнутий з
підвищенням
вона у дніпропетровської великим profi
s'cool для неї став мета tabbert для
біженців
дорога дорожнім з вуха планово боям і
луганська відривала багата води за станом
не за родом that shows рибного місця
марія правило підвалі палаюче світло
трильйони
ситуація там дружина пружина навіть
страшно там мирним мішкан сам бам бляти
буваєте ми приїхали сюди був барахти
наші жити а ми приїхали сюди для того
щоб зберегти життя собі
вона взяла з собою лише it tastes могла
дон st60 та 4 річкова жінка залу shallow
луганського 3-кімнатну квартиру та дачу біля
табурет для біженців у нас може праною
мені 3 і перепад же ти раніше тут бугурт
вже тоді воді та в трамваїв мар'яни
підвищуючи страх за її сина, яке за лиж
і вся в зоні бойових дій коли
диверсанти їздили на машинах води теми
місця та розстрілювали мирних перехожих на
машинах диверсанти та розстрілюють
ті люди, що йдуть населення, і стала свитком
і страшного насильства мало хто гірший
воріт і про по боччі на тему про тулку
приймають лише одинокий і дітей бурятті
що людину може виявити з
сепаратистами живців гарбуза із села по
оку донецька людини і син і
за втратила а
адже мій іди ти там проектуєш на шахті
він і вже дорослий там чотири особистий внук
і ранку погоду вати то завжди і втратила
щодо проти ти там теж треба годувати
aspects кидати це бачите старець там
працювати
марія розговляється склад втечі то харчів
все це
біженцям жертвувати дніпропетровці
джинси з її пенсії у тисячу гривень
швидше за допомогою чужого місця на лижі
ти про таких як на додати волонтери
з доббі шоу студенти алли що дня про
бувають за дві сотні нових біженців
тому нам потрібно вбив по жертв
більше харчів більше про біг без у тебе
просто все
марія нестеренка правило у таборі для
біженців
чують porsche уніч його робила темряву у
студентському гурту рідко жінка пробуде
тут до 1 разів не поки студенти на
канікулах
думаю що центр задає центр допомоги та
нас на та завищувати на вулиці
вали пройдуть студенти одягаються знайдуть
нам трохи менше
дніпропетровськ продовжуючи прайма то
біженців біля team місця стоять і далі ваші
розмістить і всіх хто вимагатиме а по моїм